sayad sidaoui bonjour merci d'être avec
nous à quel point la situation en syrie
est préoccupante actuellement
moi je pense avant de développer
l'analyse il faut poser la grande
question qui a invité les forces turques
en syrie est ce que la présence turque
est légitime selon le droit
international
que faut-il les forces turques ont ciré
nous savons bien qu'ils sont en train de
soutenir et des finances et les
terroristes déjà bateau nostra et d'al
quaida rappelons le géo byden le vice
président d'obama l'époque a déclaré
devant les étudiants de l'université de
harvard aux états unis d'amérique mon
ami ardo gare à ce tueur et aidés et
armés d'âge afin d'éliminer le régime de
bachar al assad
donc c'est ça la grande question mais
ils disent ils sont la lecture qu'ils
sont là afin d'aider des théories sur
place l'armée arabe syrienne a le droit
et le devoir de libérer son territoire
selon le droit international
est ce qu'elle est en train de faire
maintenant et selon des sources russes
ces soldats turcs et officiers turcs
sont mélangés avec les terroristes donc
on va pas voir la différence puisque l
aident et soutiennent les terroristes
à mon avis tôt tard la turquie va se
retirer et à se retirer des territoires
syriens la même chose les terroristes
vont être vaincus
parce qu'on est face à une armée
populaire nationale déterminer qui est
là l'armée arabe syrienne
oui alors en rien d'un sidaoui vous
dites ce que la turquie fait
actuellement en syrie mais pourquoi elle
y est quel serait son intérêt sont
intéressés déstabiliser le régime sait
rien puisque ce plombier déstabiliser le
régime progressiste laïque de bachar al
assad est là depuis longtemps
la turquie a c'est aux lecteurs qui
c'est le paradis des mobs ont des frères
musulmans dans toute la région et qu'au
prix en syrie la turquie à des
territoires a des frontières communes
avec la syrie et veut
veut profiter de la situation syrienne
veut profiter afin de sceller des bases
militaires durable et aidé les
terroristes c'est l'objet le grand
objectif évidemment c'est damas mais
erdogan d'autres puissances mondiales
ont compris qu'ils ont subi une défaite
que le plan d'éliminer l'orgie
progressiste lake de bachar al assad a
échoué
les turcs résiste erdogan ne résiste
puisqu'il à cette frontière commune et
se prétend comme à nouveau sultan
hautement il veut la même chose en libye
en envoyant ses soldats et ses officiers
évidemment quand on intervient quand on
occupe et légalement d'autres
territoires lui à la résistance donc il
ya des morts et des blessés au sol des
forces militaires turcs à mon avis
erdogan est en train de perdre et
laisser me en plus dans un peu dans une
procédure très dangereuse il dit à ses
citoyens dieu que vous allez voir je
suis le nouveau sultan hautement on va
libérer la syrie de ce régime laïque
athée ainsi de suite et le mobilise à
l'intérieur mais il subit des pertes
énormes en réalité ceux qui veulent va
les mettre dans une position très très
fragile convaincre que son opinion
publique aujourd'hui qui pose des
questions aux restait entière en syrie
il va perdre encore plus en plus ou se
retirer
c'est la défaite déclaré est ce qu'il
veut il veut éviter à n'importe quel
prix cette défaite déclaré alors
justement ar douanes à déclencher un
afflux de réfugiés syriens vers l'europe
est ce que c'est un peu son moyen de
pression pour que l'union européenne le
soutiennent toujours ils utilisent des
moyens de chantage en fait des pressions
pour un chantage vous m'aider sinon je
laisse les réfugiés aller en europe nous
savons bien que l'union européenne est
devenue très très sensible face à la
question migratoire saf face à tout ce
qui est réfugié mais à mon avis aussi
l'opinion publique européenne a compris
les manoeuvres les manoeuvres vendeurs
de galles c'est trop tard maintenant je
pense la bataille militaire décisive à
idleb et il sera bientôt libérer des
terroristes et des forces occupantes du
rck
alors l'union roc
et elle n'en craint un conflit majeur
pourtant la russie a dit qu'elle était
prête à travailler à la sécurité des
soldats turcs en syrie c'est plutôt un
signe d'apaisement
le problème si on ne peut pas toujours
avoir confiance son ordi gagnent tout
simplement il ne tient pas il ne tient
pas ses promesses ne tient pas les
accords on l'a vu même avec le président
tunisien au nigeria et la prononcer dès
des déclarations qui ont poussé la
présidence tunisienne où la présidence
algérienne à démentir ce qu'elle dit
hors dogan plus tard donc c'est très
difficile de croire
or dogan c'est très difficile parce que
l'expérience l'a bien montré
elle tient pas parole et elle est en
train de subir des défaites militaires
et les blessés on a peur vraiment que ça
devient de pire
mais de toute façon comme c'est dit
c'est est une approche stratégique
l'armée arabe syrienne va libérer toute
la syrie des forces occupantes que ce
soit terroriste ou turcs et c'est un
droit et devoir à la fois
riadh sidaoui merci pour vos réponses
rappelle que vous êtes politologue et
directeur du karaté merci merci à vous